yo guys what's up prestigious here and
Treyarch has released a vine video about
call of duty next DLC so let's look at
it this is their vine video and it's
it's basically all about their new the
new DLC pack dlc for and i'm gonna break
it down for you guys right to see right
now you see i slowed it down a bit it's
called everything starts with the
beginning and this is what i think they
think basically everyone else thinks and
knows kind of that this is going to be
when they bring back a bunch of old
black ops 1 maps now i'm going to pause
it at certain points and i'll show you
what i think first thing this looks like
a tea so i'm assuming the name of the
new map pack is gonna new dlc he's gonna
have Tina somewhere yeah kind of
basically with that and there's gonna be
a new map make sure you know that all
right here we have the moon this moon
looks like it's from Nocturne tone which
is the very first zombies map which is
something that's not like a fun
exclusive so that they might be also
bringing back is so you don't know
obviously this is the if you don't know
this is the first like this is the first
dombey's map so everything start with
the beginning it would make sense that
they would bring this they might try and
end the zombies series here and if they
have the new characters go back to hear
that would be good closure for ya next
up we have this little thingy here now I
saw another youtuber liam ft winter did
amusing his idea so matchmaking online
they came out with a pack a punch deal a
camo that had these gold bars so just
referencing pack-a-punch world at war
pack a punch here I have no idea what
this thing is yeah I don't know what it
is next up this could be a satchel
charge or something like that I don't
know here we have this what looks to me
like a browning machine gun which one of
the two LMGs they could find in the
original zombies browning or mg42 it
looks more like a Browning to me i'm
gonna bet that as a browning machine and
1911 maybe i'll know this looks like a
flashbang or something of the sorts
that's all i can think about that here
this is one of the comp there's another
math confirmation i actually didn't play
this map but a lot of people saying this
is
in this minus 2 which I'm going to go
with the crowd I'm gonna say this is
ascension if it's not I got a wrong
sorry but I'm going to detention and
lastly this looks like a shangri-la I
haven't even played jenga lot and this
looks like shangri-la another zombies
map more kind of out there crazy stuff
and yeah so if you guys have enjoyed
this video make sure you leave the like
rate comment or subscribe and hopefully
yeah there's another tea this is that
see I hope goes hopefully you all
enjoyed makes really like great comfort
described I'll see y'all later
you